For that little invisibility trick he does, Harry may have to ditch the cloak and go with fishnets.
Scientists have created a new cloaking technique...
...that not only can hide three-dimensional objects from microwave detection...
...but is light, thin and flexible, traits lacking in previous attempts at invisibility.
The new material called a Metascreen is constructed of strips of copper tape...
...just 66 micrometers thick, the thickness of a human hair,...
...attached to 100-micrometer-thick polycarbonate film in a fishnet design.
When hit by microwaves, the new metamaterial scatters and cancels the waves,...
...rendering anything the cloak is hiding,...
...like an 18-centimeter cylinder in the test case, invisible from all angles.
Dubbed "mantle cloaking" by its creators, this furtive fishnet would be easy to manufacture...
...and could, in principle, be scaled to cloak objects from light.
But with a caveat.
Mantle cloaking scales inversely to the operational wavelength.
So Harry, already a pretty small dude, would need to be a micrometer in size.